I mean that was our one connection then
you had my brother on your podcast
talking about bukaki your brother you
know here's the thing that I'll never
forget about your brother when when he
was telling me one of the things he was
telling me was that
you know he he was like I was on he was
on heroin and
he was he kept saying this thing that
that has never left me which was he had
a job he had like I think real estate or
something and he was like you know I
kept like I couldn't I just couldn't get
it to get like I would show up late or I
would forget the thing
I you know where I would so I was
supposed to be here but I just I
couldn't get it together right and every
and I remember him telling me all this
stuff and for some reason
it's like when someone says something
and dots connect all the times in my
life where I've thought about somebody
being like that and you want to go the
[ __ ] is going on with you man it made me
go like oh maybe that person was on
drugs and that and that like drugs where
you go falling down strung out clearly
on drugs it was he was doing drugs but
still
you know participating in like trying to
work and those kind of people always
made me crazy where you're like dude
it's [ __ ] 10 o'clock like where are
you and he kept telling me how he was
like every time I had an appointment or
I was supposed to do something I would
just like [ __ ] it up somehow but it was
because
I was either on heroin or looking for
heroin or trying to get heroin and it's
never left me I think about it all the
time about all the times that you're
trying to like you know get something
done with someone and you're like what
is wrong with you yeah there's your
Spidey senses are going off and they're
just they're disheveled and there's like
unmanageability they're eight minutes
late for everything [ __ ] sorry
they're like sweating it's like and that
was like he was like oh yeah that was
that was heroin yeah that was me like
trying to get through life but having
heroin pulled me in this direction yeah
it's probably safe to say that if
somebody's like that there's definitely
something pulling them in that where
it's not a priority right exactly
exactly you know because it's like that
doesn't like
you're sober I mean that's sober but
like yeah yeah but not on you're on
point you know you're you're business
savvy and like you tell us to get here
at a certain time you're here we're here
it's like we got [ __ ] to do everybody
you kind of you know but like there's
also like people you know this is like
we're all you know friends and doing
this but like we're also like when you
hire someone or you're like hey you're
like hey man show me this property and
the person's like
not answering and then you're the [ __ ]
are you doing their address is off
slightly and you're like dude you're a
real estate guy how are you not doing
this you know yeah but for so like for
some reason he has been that story for
me is one of those things that is like
it's a file in my head ever since he
said it I I always think of it when
somebody is off yeah I'm like maybe this
person's on drugs yeah he'll be super
happy to know that too well I mean he
and also I'll tell you this as somebody
I saw him do stand up
um at the store like
I don't know five years ago and I was
like oh you know there's kernels of like
a funny guy here and stuff and then I've
seen him on Instagram posting clips now
he has gotten like light years better
yeah he's gotten really good yeah he's
been he's been practicing a lot and he
just had a kid too I didn't know that he
and Chelsea him and Chelsea it's called
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on Amazon and type in Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude